[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Linc and I'm
Rhett this week at the round table of
dim lighting we are exploring the
question how do we deal with a medical
crisis and let me just say first of all
we're both fine neither one of us are
personally in a medical crisis right by
this is something that happened over the
last over the past me personally but
person and I have been dealing with a
family medical crisis which I'd love to
just be able to verbally process through
with you
gentle listener as well as you gentle
friend and I don't want to I'm not
trying to spoil anything here yet but we
should the this person that you're gonna
be talking about is fine now yes so I
cuz it cuz because we're gonna be having
fun this is gonna be this is gonna be
also light-hearted yeah if we're gonna
talk about some serious things that
happen but we're also gonna be having a
good time
joking because in the end everything is
okay well this is what happened and you
know I I'll walk through the details
well and unpack it well first we got to
let people know we're gonna keep telling
you all about our date educating you
about where we're going to be where
you're coming to a town near you if you
happen to be in Las Vegas we're going to
be there on June 21st
Salt Lake City June 22nd Denver the 23rd
Milwaukee the 25th Indianapolis 226
Detroit the 27th Omaha the 29th and
Minneapolis on the 30th again this is
rhett and Link live in concert not the
tour of mythicality
and debuting well if you've seen them
all there's some new songs that you have
never been heard before on the internets
and then of course the old classics the
rap battles there's there's potential
dress-up that happened dress up that is
a good way to put it anyway it's we play
dress up you buy a ticket we play dress
up and there's also VIP tickets
available of course you're all very
important people that's just the
industry vernacular to describe someone
who pays
a ticket where we get to have a little
meet-and-greet so all that and more at
rhettandlink live.com come see us
rattling live.com so uh in some ways I
am still very much processing what
happened over the past week and it
involves my mom's husband Lewis who I've
talked about many times he's technically
my stepdad because he's my mom's husband
but he's not my dad
he's your stepdad that's what I just
said but I've never I've never actually
ended up calling him my stepdad I'll end
up saying something like he's my
father-in-law it is if I'm presen
correct but because in strange he
married my mom I mean they were dating
when I was in high school and you know
I've known it for a long time and I
loved him but he didn't raise you I do
love him any but he didn't raise me and
I didn't I never lived with him so when
you know I got married and then Christy
was pregnant with Lilly and that's when
my mom and Lois got married so we've got
there's an interesting dynamic to the
nature of our relationship that I love
him but he's not he is my stepdad but I
don't call him that boys he doesn't in
experience it just doesn't feel like
what a stepdad actually I think that my
mom's husband is the correct well that's
true too
no I know but I'm just a father alive if
I meet a is not if I meet a person if
I'm just had a party and I'm having a
conversation with somebody they begin
telling me a story and they say my mom's
husband I immediately know oh not your
stepdad you stepped out of somebody who
you usually would say raise you right
but father-in-law you got to stop saying
that
but father-in-law what's gonna happen is
you're gonna be seen with him in public
at some point and they're gonna be like
oh that's your father-in-law I know this
is my father then you're one of those
guys that has two families one being
secret okay and you can't have it I
can't be one of those guys well I mean I
do have a secret family but I don't have
nothing to do with this I will say that
Shepard asked me there were something in
the clear something in the car
and when he got into the car the other
day and he was like where's this from I
said oh that's from that's when one of
the kids in my hand my secret family
left it I just couldn't help myself
is it hopefully he meant imaginary
family I said you know like a lot of
people have a second family and heaps oh
don't joke about oh I thought she said
this is Shepherd you see Hadlock it was
Shepherd oh you just said like uh you
mention
okay I'm a shepherd dog okay anyway I
joke like that with my children they
know that it's a joke so get off my case
but was he joking when he told you is
the question he didn't tell me instead
where is this from and I said it's from
oh you said that yeah I messed up I
think everyone else understood I don't
know if I said it in a confusing way but
I'm sorry it's so confused
so anyway Louis my father-in-law it does
come into the story later by the way he
he's doing well now but he had I'm not I
don't want to over sensationalize it but
well then just sensationalized I'll just
say but I do think it was a brush with
mortality brush with death it took some
time for that to sink in
and so I'll impact that like I said some
of us I'm still I'm still processing but
he gave me permission to talk about it
here and take it for what it's worth my
mom and Louis they came they came out
here last year and then we visited for
Thanksgiving and then that's the last
time we've seen him in person so they
kind of wanted to come out again
but they've got they got a house they
got farmland he drives around his farm
land on his Gator and he surveys his
land and he sees
turkeys and he keeps an eye on how many
turkeys that come around and for those
of you don't understand what a gator is
it he doesn't mean he's like on an
alligator he's on like a it's like a
John Deere crazy awkward guard kind of
thing I kind of wanted the mystique to
be that maybe he's just saddled an
alligator but fine well if you want to
believe that yeah go ahead
clear up the mystique we got he's got
cows mom named some of them and then he
takes care of him they have babies he
makes sure that everything's good to go
you know he's got basically he's a farm
to run
right so it's hard to get away and
they're not the traveling type mm-hmm so
we planned this a long time in advance
and I think mom came down with something
they had to they had to reschedule in
time something came up I can't remember
but then we can before last they were
coming out and they were gonna show up
Friday night and then they were gonna
they like to stay in a hotel not at our
house so we you know we make him feel
comfortable whatever way they want and
then they were gonna fly back Monday
they weren't that's a quick trip they
were only staying in two days those cows
they got to get back to the house and we
were very much looking forward to making
the most of those two days so we pick
him up at the airport the whole family's
in the car and like we're crammed into
there and we pick him up at the curb and
I I can immediately tell that like Louis
is his road ragged he doesn't look great
and I'm like man the flight must not
have been great they get in the car put
the luggage in and we're driving them it
was late so especially by their time so
we were trying to we just went straight
to their hotel you say anything at that
point yeah they like you look awful
which is you shouldn't say that to
someone round they get out of a plane um
I've made that mr. did not look good but
I was like well how was the flight and
they said it was okay a lot of
turbulence Louis didn't have much
appetite they didn't say much about
turbulence or anything like that but
they were I mean he was very quiet and
you may have heard me talk about this
before but the thing we love to talk
about Louis is that he's got this catch
phrase good good good like if he's
talking to the kids you know the whole
week leading up to them coming I'm
talking to all the kids and I'm like I'm
talking like Louis I'm like doing my
impersonation of them like Lincoln
you've been doing your push-ups how's
basketball and I'm like Lincoln you're
not playing basketball anymore so you
got to be ready for your answer because
you know pop I was gonna ask you about
basketball and you push up buddy just
make up your knee so he had his knees to
prepare and I was like you can just tell
your mountain biking with your dad and
you're still staying active and then
he'll just say good good good giving
your kids answers just trying to just
let them come up with their own answers
man but we were looking forward to that
catchphrase and I couldn't help but
notice he was quiet and there was no
good good Goods happening on the ride to
the to the hotel but he wasn't saying
bad bad bad he was not that does it go
that no and I took a wrong turn and me
and Christy kind of snapped at each
other a little bit what about the GPS I
was like well you know how when
sometimes your phone's hooked up to the
cords and then it the Maps not showing
up on the car play and and I'm having to
drive but I can't see the turn and now
I'm going the wrong way and I'm getting
angry and I got to direct that anger at
somebody even though my mama's in the
car and haven't seen her in person since
Thanksgiving I'm not gonna direct it
towards my mom or Louis so Christy got a
little bit of that she gave it right
back good
she yeah good good good good I deserved
it and then so I thought that the
silence might have been as a result of
me being right okay we get to the hotel
we check him in there they're tired you
know we let him we let him go to sleep
we're gonna I was like we'll come pick
you up as early as you want in the
morning you're on the East Coast time
well mom never called so we finally
called about mid-morning and she's like
Louis is not doing well he's he kind of
if he's feeling faint and he's he's
passing blood when he uses the bathroom
and I'm like well not good good good
mm-hm so we come we pick him up and
we're like we go straight to the
emergency room no explain that decision
to me because when you're when you're
passing blood well no no but I'm need to
go hardest no I'm telling you I'm
telling you like I I am the kind of
person that always minimizes you know
what I'm saying yeah I'm that way - this
is Christy driving this train right so
Christy Christy is she's good in those
situations she has a natural nursing
instinct yeah I've never nursed her just
just do you understand great
I but she has that like she's kind of
she's good in medical situations she
kind of there's a certain mode
yeah those into like this ready
contingency mode then when we were going
to sleep the night before she was like
now the nearest hospital where they're
staying in Pasadena is like the
Huntington well the hospitals of you who
understand the India Graham a six is
really well equipped that's what she is
at these sort of contingency plans so
she she was like I think Louis wasn't
doing good and if we're gonna we may
have to take into the emergency room she
already said that in line before right
that's why she was calling mommy they
they checked him in and he he was I
don't I don't actually don't think he
passed more blood when he was there and
then you know it takes a while to
process and they like they said we're
gonna we're gonna admit you because
something's going on here there's
internal bleeding and you know or
there's evidence to that and your blood
count is low they check him in to the
ICU intensive care unit and so they're
monitoring very closely and one of the
nurses said to mom your husband is very
sick I was like well what is that
what does that mean we don't know yet
the the the gastro doctor comes in and
they did a scope from down his throat
they like they like put him under for a
little bit we stepped out of the room
and they in like less than a half hour
they did this procedure where they put
the scope down his esophagus through his
stomach looking at everything into a
small intestine and then we come back in
there and he's already awake again but
the news is Lewis has over 10 all sirs
in his small intestine hmm good gracious
this does not sound good and the doc not
the stomach the small intestine yeah the
duodenum duodenum
you say it yeah I hope you take that out
you can stretch it around the earth nine
times just Lois's you know how long is
this yeah yeah just an individual's oh
okay that can't be truth but it can't
quickly light travel to the speed of
light I think around the earth nine
times in a second I don't know
I'm confusing facts the doctor gave us
the good news that even though there's
so many he's what I don't know if this
is a southern saying because the doctor
didn't say it he was from LA he wouldn't
but what I would say is he's eat up with
our ulcers he's eat up with him mm-hmm
but he said there was one in particular
that looked bigger and it had a scab
that had formed over it just like skin
on the outside of your body um I'm sorry
I'm surprised I'm able to talk about it
we can get into that more later but he
said that just like skin on the outside
of your body on the inside of your
intestine if it can it forms a scab with
which then it heals and he said I
agitated the scab you know it's amazing
you put the scope down there with a with
a camera take pictures you see the live
video you can and you can blast water
and also medication through this scope
there and they can control it like with
a like a kind of thing like once it gets
down there it was actually very easy to
control you can like nibble a tit he he
said you want to try it and then it was
it was like two joysticks no I didn't
see I didn't see the thing man we went
outside I don't know how many joysticks
there were I'm just assuming that to be
that precise like it has some sort of
you know mechanical head on at the
moment I was not asking about the
mechanical head again that's what I do
in these situations because I don't want
to talk about the real you deflect I
know I want to talk about let's talk
about the mechanics and the machinery
that's inside of everything how about
that but he said he sprayed over a
little water and then it all evidence
pointed to the fact that it was going to
stay which was great news and it also
meant that you know if the if they
monitored him and there was no more
bleeding that that meant that there
wasn't any other source of bleeding
lower down and like the rest of his GI
tract
because to do a colonoscopy to go from
the top up
you'd have yeah at the bottom up yeah
yeah from the bottom up you'd have to
wait to to like totally clean out the
entire system and that was just more
time that but anyway at that point we
were in a holding pattern and because
that equipment is very expensive you
don't want it all over it and yes red
that's exactly what it is I'm trying not
to be that graphic and I see you they
they make everyone leave while they have
shift change so just so happens that we
had made reservations for this Japanese
Steakhouse before we knew any of this
was gonna take a break go you some
Japanese so we're like gonna you make me
feel horrible about it but like Christy
was like I'm gonna stay around we have
reservations linker
Grant granny why don't you go and see
the kids and just take a break because
you're not we're not allowed to be in
here anyway yeah and it's very close and
it was it one when they throw the shrimp
in the Hat yeah they showed the entire
volcano made of onions I thought that
would be nice oh yeah it's always nice
so Christy stayed back so she was like
very much in proximity even though she
wasn't allowed to be in there and then I
took mom because we had good news and we
were in a holding pattern oh so you went
to the Japanese I went to yeah me and
mom met Britain and the kids that we met
at the at the Japanese Steak how did you
get it combo chicken shrimp and beef yes
you're deflecting now no I really am
interested in what people order it that
I always get the combo and I'm you know
we're all on edge but it was it was nice
for her to see the kids cuz otherwise
she wasn't able to see them and I go up
to use the restroom right before he
starts flipping shrimp and as I'm
walking to the restroom I look up and
dadgum if it in the scope doctor the
freakin scope doctor the ghetto guy okay
was at the Japanese restaurant heard you
guys talking about this but I didn't
understand that that this was the story
yeah he was one of those hibachi guys he
worked there yeah yeah well you know
what doctors these days don't make
enough money right you got him he was
there with his family at another table
and I went
I was like I found myself upon him by
surprise on my way to the bathroom so
I'm I'm in his face and I'm like I
recognize him I'm like hey Doc I'm you
just you were just treating my
father-in-law right yeah and again I
just said I just came out with
father-in-law and it worked here cuz he
doesn't know and he understands that
it's not you know I don't know what he
understood but it was easy right he just
got the chicken though but it was a
doctor
it was weird cuz it was like one of
those moments where remember in like um
well I remember in middle school when I
went to Walmart one time when I was in
third grade and like I saw miss Hobbs my
third grade teacher in like the yeah
chips island Walmart they have they can
be outside of school as well and like
she started talking to me and I felt
really weird and I got embarrassed and I
was like how did I get grade on this
conversation yeah I felt it I felt like
a third grader in the hibachi restaurant
talking to my teacher right it was weird
but he was very nice and he came over
and he talked to mom and she was very
appreciative because we had good news at
that he was like you want to see some
pictures of the ulcers
he had already shown us those but it out
of the restaurant yeah but not right
there and then I was like we brought the
kids back and we took them up to see
Lewis when they allowed us to go back
into ICU and the nurse had a funny look
on her face
and I looked around into the room and
like Louis did not look good at all I
looked worse and then the kids like said
hello and then it was kind of like why
don't Christina it back later because
the plan was we were all leaving and mom
was just gonna stay because we were but
it it it took a while for it to really
sink in but I mean what had happened was
he had started passing blood again again
and this sounds like a great place for a
teaser be good because we need to say we
need to do a short break people know Oh
things got worse things get worse before
they get better but they do
it's but we are gonna take a short break
and let you know that you can get these
mugs we're drinking out of you can't get
this one this was a this was a prototype
I don't even know why I've got it I'm
this is just to tempt you with something
you can't buy we prototyped all types of
things in order to land on the perfect
thing for your mouths your bodies your
hairs I'm trying to blend in completely
today as you can see I have two
different brown mugs I have a brown
hoodie on I have brown hair hair brownie
something it's all kind of blending in
with the background and I kind of think
this might be my new thing what are you
selling you're having focus issues today
I'm selling beige Ness that's not for
sale
mmm it kind of is though you'll see and
you'll understand what I'm getting that
months from now but in the meantime what
you can buy is these mugs and lots of
other cool things over at mythical got
store the hindsight of the experience
it just seems much more clear than when
it's hat when when things are
progressing in the hospital it you know
the the nurses and doctors are reacting
to things and it's not that they're not
communicating but it's the combination
of them doing their jobs trying to
communicate but also the ability for
that to sink in for to be able to
receive the information every you know
the doctor would just drop in
occasionally and it's go time to like
have your questions
could you imagine just and that's
difficult did you imagine being the
person like and neither one of us would
be good at that
we might be good at any new patient the
dope the nurse oh gosh like having to do
something but then also explain to
someone in a sympathetic tone what's
actually happening forget about it what
one of my big takeaways from this thing
is I haven't a just a blossomed
appreciation specifically for nurses in
a hospital environment it they they are
amazing people who do an amazing
difficult job and that that's a big part
of it interacting not only with the
patient but with the the loved ones who
are there
present and for me it's like I'm
bringing my kids one of my kids is too
young to actually be there and I'm
breaking the rules for him to come up so
you know and then there was the age
limit for teen in the ICU and they let
you do that
well yeah 14 year old but not a nine
year old no but you were able to get
Landon well I I just kind of went up
with him because I was like he's Lois is
fine and he'll his spirits will be
lifted by seeing you for a minute that
that was not smart I should have I
should have respect that ruled the nurse
actually told me he could see things in
the ICU that well he was a nine-year-old
may not want to be etched on his brain
oh wow I'm an idiot and you really made
a good point I'm gonna take my kids out
of here now you know it's just like my
head space was so this is gonna be over
at any moment this is gonna be okay we
already got good news yes he has ulcers
yes he's got to figure that stuff out
and there's gonna be more treatment to
come when he gets back home but he's
he's out he's in the clear when we got
back I mean Chrissy took the kids away
and they're just they had already been
giving him blood because he had lost
blood already the night before I think
by this point they would give it they
were giving him like six seven eight
pints of blood already I'm telling you I
mean I was there this is like 10 o'clock
at night 11 o'clock at night midnight
and then because you don't you don't
have that much I told you about this
recently yeah for the book we we had to
oh you don't want to say that well no I
we had - okay I said we I had to look up
for a part of the book we were working
on how much blood is in a human body
yeah and that's the answer I think the
average adult just has like two gallons
of blood how many pints is that I don't
know three pints in a gallon and
hopefully more than that for I thought
it was only four pie
in the gallon all I can all I'm saying
is eco we'll look it up because we're
stupid there's a lot less blood in a
human body
and so giving him that much blood like
he didn't have hardly any well and then
the the thing is he would he was he was
confined to the bed
what does it get go science and then how
many you said there were how many
gallons and about two gallons of blood
and a body so 16 pints look that up to I
want to make sure I how many pints of
blood in an average body because I will
say by the end of this they gave him 12
pints of blood but how many 12 they gave
complaints so that's wow so they Alan
and a half of blood in an average person
but I'm telling you right now
they gave him enough blood that fills up
a human body yeah that's crazy that's
what's so surprised me because and um
yes in the Moret and again it's like
they kept giving him when they were
giving him two three four five concerns
start to raise my man and they said okay
we're going to have to we're gonna have
to give him a central line we can't we
can't use the IVs to keep up with him
passing the blood and it was a very
visceral experience which he doesn't
remember any of even though he was
conscious he was talking but he wasn't
very lucid and yeah you know as you can
imagine right and in that situation you
can't move him out of the bed and he's
he's passing blood I mean it's it's a
visceral and horrible situation to be
bedside for that okay and this is coming
from the guy who you can't take any
amount of blood in the thought of
needles and they're sitting there
filling and again his father-in-law
yeah just fill him up with I mean how
he's like a fountain it's just passing
through him did you go into a mental
space
like a nun before tapped never before
tap mental space in order to get through
this without fainting whenever they
would earlier on whenever he started
passing blood and they would clean him
up I would step out I mean but I felt
like that was just like to give him
privacy and for them to do their job so
you were again I guess I wasn't him
I was in a zone of like it was kind of a
it was just it was a bit of a fog it was
like not realizing how dire things are
getting but then when they said we need
to give him a central line in his neck
so that we can pump blood in and keep up
with how quickly he's losing blood and
we're getting the doctor back in here to
do another scope in order to see where
the new bleeding is coming from we're
just goes to show you not only how
important blood is like how you know
there are these places there's so many
places on earth that don't even have
adequate amounts of you know clean blood
yeah yeah I mean it's your privilege
just to be in a place that you can lose
that much blood and immediately have it
replenished I don't know what the PSA is
here but give blood I thought about the
part of yeah yeah and also be willing to
take blood there was never a
conversation about that well I know yeah
if you there are people who if you
currently subscribe to a worldview that
doesn't allow you to take blood
reevaluate that worldview well he would
have died that's my second PSA he would
have died within a few hours to be at
the hospital he wouldn't have got
anywhere close to this if he could if he
couldn't take blood I mean they couldn't
they couldn't find a central line in his
neck that worked and they had to do a
central line in his groins and then and
basically his hip and then they're
pumping him full of blood in order to
just gain time and it was at that point
that I realized that like oh my gosh
this is this is very dire
I mean this is touch and go and how's
your mom handling this at the time she
was in more I I wouldn't call that she
was in a fog she was in more of a
supportive she was very positive and I
mean she was going to work in terms of
just being positive and in support mode
it was and she comes was amazing she's
comes from a medical background yeah I'm
like a clinical yes so she took blood
for a living and like from she's she's
used to being around blood and like
medical environments yeah so she wasn't
shaken up by that but she said later
that it it dawned on her the next
morning how dire things were there I
just think that she was in a mode where
she wasn't allowing herself to to to go
to the the dark potentials okay the dark
potential the dark potentials that's the
name of our second novel but they the
doctor finally showed up any you know
they got ahead of it a little the
bleeding a little bit but he was I mean
it was it was scary because there was
blood all over the bed
and they would just they couldn't keep
up with it so they would put a blanket
down over him and he was you know he he
was disoriented so at times he would
look down and he would move the blanket
and he would see all the blood or he
wouldn't see it and his hand would be
his hand would like go down there to
feel what's going on this is tough for
people to see and I guess the reason the
the reason why I share it is because I
think you you never know what I could
never imagine that I would be bedside
for a situation like that and I'm with
my mom and it was I'm glad that we were
able to be supportive but it it was very
scary and I never would have thought
that I would have been able to be to
contribute to a supportive environment
when it was that scary well which is
that okay so I'm I'm not
by no I'm surprised I'm not bragging I'm
just saying like these things happen and
maybe you go in a mode but if you don't
it's I feel more prepared having gone
through it to be more support I do think
that I will say that the human brain is
really complex and I think that what
ends up happening a lot of times is you
know that you can't afford to check out
I think there are certain situations
where you can't afford to check out like
when you cut yourself at Christmas it's
like he has that big of a deal didn't
st. into your real father in law's arms
right you know so but my question is did
you why were you the one that was there
it was just circumstantial
circumstantial it's Sansa's because of
the way that you brought the kids in and
then you didn't know how bad it was
gonna get because you if you think about
how bad it was going to get and Christy
and you both knew how bad it was going
to get and then to make it a year to
make a decision he was gonna stay you
probably would have picked Christy to
stay and you would have gone home with
the kids
no because it was your your relations
yeah it was because I mean mom well
I'll back into that because I do think
it's it's interesting because I feel so
much and I felt so much for Louis and
mom because they don't travel and then
they find themselves going through this
situation so far from home with no with
no support structure beyond me and
Christy like they know no one else
except they might have met people in
passing through us but there's no one
like back home Lewis has an extended
family that they're very tight-knit yeah
so his real name is Edie I think Louis
is his middle name
Edie with two DS and in the hospital
they kept asking him what's your name
and then in order to give medication to
do treatment they had or just know if he
was lucid they would ask him his name
and they were expecting him and say Edie
and he would say Louis so they would
think it was worse than it was but his
brother Edie he's got a brother
had Ted and Fred yeah it's unbelievable
you know and and you better believe they
all would have been there as well as you
know his children and everybody else who
who loves him and obviously would have
been there to support him mid did Fred
and Ed and Peggy yeah there's not
there's not a good typical woman name
they call her pad no they don't
there may be other siblings I can't
remember but anyway because they're out
here like it's just me and Christy with
mom to two we find ourselves in this
weird situation where we're the only
support that they've got so when we had
to send the kids I was like well mom's
gonna stay there for Louis and I'm gonna
stay there for Mom I'm gonna support mom
and mom's gonna support Louis and then
that I honestly that's the first way
that I thought about it I think that
changed over that night and the next few
days but we could talk about that some
more but at this point yeah I would we
did actively make that decision for me
to be there with mom and so by 1:00 a.m.
the doctor's showing back up and doing
the scope and finding that that problem
ulcer was basically at this point
obviously gushing blood and then use
that trigger warning on this episode to
put maybe my I think maybe I'm able to
talk about this in a way that like maybe
I feel differently about blood now well
but you're also the one saying it so
it's not capping and it happened he
unexpected and he's able to use that
scope in his hibachi hands right I've
still got chicken grease on and he's he
sprayed some like epinephrine you think
he puts the redneck sauce on on his
chicken he puts his redneck sauce on
that ulcer and it just sutures right up
that the the creamy sauce that you can
get at that bocce place we always call
redneck sauce because only that you go
over to Japan they don't have that sauce
okay that something rednecks came out
with now it's good I took the whole Bowl
that night and I just poured it all over
my plate
like I'm a redneck yeah I can feel my
mullet growing so so he epinephrine he
put some epinephrine on it and and it
basically sutured it up it's a
vasoconstrictor and then who knew and he
showed us what he did and he showed us
pictures of it and I'm thinking man I
saw you at the freaking hibachi it like
seven o'clock you can't be here now it's
1:00 a.m. and you're here right and I'm
in third grade it's so weird
that was excellent news but as we were
waiting for him to do the scope mom and
I had to step out and just wait and it
was like we were sitting in the in the
waiting room just the two of us no one
else was in there and we were we didn't
say a word
it was we were so exhausted it's like
somebody who's been through a battle
together yeah you just you just sit
there you just sit there and it was very
surreal and she told me that it really
hadn't sunken in at that point how dire
things were she was in that mode and
kind of in fight mode and stay positive
mode and so at that point it was very
touching the great news was they stopped
the bleed they found the bleeding they
have stopped the bleeding they didn't
have to do a second procedure which
could have damaged the kidneys in order
to try to find the bleeding or a third
procedure worst case where they had to
do surgery the surgeons were coming in
and like prepping him for that too in
case they had it was it was that
everybody that everybody was buzzing
around and it was yeah it was very
kinetic and it was it was real man
and by that morning he had stabilized
and of course he wasn't giving any drink
or food for probably the next 48 hours
as it turns out but they were moderate
giving they were hydrating him
intravenously yeah
else he would die and giving him
medicine for the ulcers and giving him
medicine to help the you know to
preserve them from bleed
and giving him more blood you know can
come out of that come out to a total of
14 units 14 pints so again he replaced
his blood supply yeah
he completely revised his but blood
supply it's wild and so then everybody
needs that it's like changing your
transmission fluid every once in a while
that I mean that's literally what
happened but it was it what they didn't
drain him out and then fill him up it
was a constant flow it was more of yeah
you can't you can you can't do that with
a human
it was the nightmare you can do that
with a car it was an absolute nightmare
and then so then for the next two days
it's kind of touch-and-go to make sure
that he's not bleeding and even though
he's not eating then as you slowly
introduce drinking and then eating foods
like clear foods and all that jazz it's
it's just continuing to monitor that
he's not bleeding and let's see so we
checked him in Saturday morning we
checked him out by the end of the week
so he was there a whole week so then it
was we at it it basically shifted from
emergency situation he left the ICU to a
regular hospital room which then you and
Jesse came that first night and visited
him there which is great but then it was
just that's when it really started to
hit us that there's only three people to
support him in his recovery as he's here
and that I mean that proved to be very
challenging because my mom stayed there
all night and then I would as soon as I
could get up in the morning I would go
in and relieve her like either Christy
would come get her or I'd send her home
to my house in an uber to take a shower
and try to sleep for a few hours and
then I would Christy and mom would come
and then I would go into work for a few
hours and then so someone was always
there with him for the whole week and I
just I really gained in
appreciation for how important it is to
have people come visit like when you
guys came that night to visit it was a
it was a tremendous help and something
that I'd never liked you know I never
appreciated when it's like someone's in
the hospital sick well you should go see
them you know you should you should go
see them because it's the right thing to
do but I never really connected the dots
that like for the people who are
actively supporting the person in
recovery it's also a huge help to them
to like you run out of stuff to talk
about you run out of it's it drains all
of your energy to sit in a hotel a hotel
in a hospital room you know and when
doctors and nurses are coming in and
just constantly pricking prodding and
doing stuff and it's not a happy it's
not Disneyland you know no no and as a
matter takeaway and we were there for a
very short period of time but first of
all I got lost okay I had I had a window
of time between leaving here and then
going to therapy and I had kind of
planned to have like half an hour and
Jesse was gonna meet me but my frickin
GPS my phone sent me to the back of the
hospital yeah that's the wrong and it's
a big Hospital you know I parked and
then I had to I mean I was like 20
minutes from my car and then when I and
then I walk into the lobby the hospital
lobby and I realize I see you checking
in and you would left work like way
after me oh yeah and that's when I see
through the window and I see like the
thing I had been looking for the whole
time like the grand Hospital entrance
would like there's there's multiple
doors and there's a big there's a big
like horseshoe where you kind of drop
people off and I saw Jesse and I was
like where'd you park she's like i
valeted yeah she went to the right
entrance so yeah I got lost I I and I'm
so sorry that happened to you man that's
kind of like having a bleeding ulcer and
almost done yeah yeah yeah but what I
was getting to is how much
I was just reminded how much ID I hate
hospitals
I know that I appreciate hospitals
they're absolutely unnecessary but like
I get in this is pricey something a lot
of people relate to it's like I've never
been in the hospital personally like
I've never had to go to the hospital for
anything I've been in like the doctor or
have had like very small procedures at
like an outpatient clinic but never been
in a hospital and when I go into a
hospital and like on the floor that Lois
was on like he had to pass by several
rooms that were open and like these
people are in different states of
disrepair
yeah and sometimes they're screaming
yeah well there's one guy who was having
a interesting exchange with a nurse yeah
there's interesting sense yeah and I
load about and again I this is I don't
know what it is I did I was going to
therapy right after that I didn't get
into this but I don't know I just get
this feeling that I'm just like I don't
want to be here and I don't want to be a
patient here ever yeah and you feel like
being here might make me sick
like I think things like that but
there's people who have to spend not
just oh gosh you know we met the kids
it's st. Jude who basically you know
some of them spent the majority of their
lives in that environment and places
like st. Jude do go to incredible
lengths to create an environment that is
not you know it's it's not depressing
and other than the fact that why you're
there yeah and this hospital was was a
great facility yeah I mean there's no
actual criticism that we could level on
the facility or the faculty in at any
point you know it's just it's more about
the stigma associated with hospitals or
the fact that like a hospital is still
it is what it is and that's in it's not
it's not a pleasant environment and it's
way more pleasant now than it was what
you know gosh fifty years ago or
whatever I mean all of this all the
procedures they were doing on Lewis they
would cart the stuff into the room and
like do the scope and everything there
was a man
I was like I was talking to him later
we're watching Leave It to Beaver one
morning I was like can you imagine back
in the day if beaver had some bleeding
ulcers what what would they have done I
think they would have be dead they
buried they just would have done up they
would have done surgery in order to find
where you were you were bleeding
I think mm-hmm you know there's no
scoping in your room and 30 minutes
later you're your wife can walk back in
and get good news and a picture of it
it's all conjecture but I was I gained
such an appreciation like I said for the
nurses and hospital staff in general and
but also a revived sense of how
important it is to visit people in the
hospital and not let the way that we
instinctively think about it like I
should visit but I'm not going to it
makes a huge huge difference and when
you guys came in and you know you you
ever lighten the mood have somebody else
to talk to pass a little bit of time you
know and obviously also
give and receive love and care you know
it's like it it can't be understated but
for some reason in my mind I think it
had gone to that place and you know what
in a few days we're coming up on the two
year anniversary of Lilly having her
spinal fusion surgery mm-hmm
as we record this it will be this coming
Friday because I put it on the calendar
two years and I'm a little discouraged
that I had forgotten what I'd learned
there the things that I'm now talking
about because in her recovery how
important it was for for people to come
and offer support and again I just felt
for for Lewis and for Mom especially
Louis because his family wasn't there
and it was an interesting situation
because you know I'm in a position where
I'm spending hours with this guy that
I've never spent you know I'll ride on
the Gator with him and the kids down and
see the cows and come back but it's not
like the two of us have a vibrant
relationship where we hang out you know
I love him because he loves my mom and
my mom loves him and they are very happy
together and they have a beautiful
relationship
and they're perfect for each other that
is that is enough for me to love him
unabashedly but in but it when a
delegator helps indicator helps but when
it comes to the experience of a
relationship I found my sit what I mean
it was an interesting position to be in
you know for him and for me probably
where you know we have to assume the
role of the people who are providing the
only emotional support for hours at a
time and you know I really had to deal
just honestly hey this is this is not
about Luis and my relationship with him
really I think it just kind of set the
stage for me to think more about like my
level of selfishness honestly a lot of
that came up because I just realized how
much I want my life to be ordered the
way I want it to be well they're gonna
come in for two days these this is our
itinerary we're gonna have a really good
time and then they're gonna leave and
get back to their cows where they want
to be and everybody's gonna be happy and
I know what my next week has in store
for me and I'm looking forward to it
it's a light week at work I can you know
I was looking forward to specific things
you know we weren't filming anything so
it was that was actually a blessing you
know because I and again I actually with
all the stuff that we have going on at
work I actually had a week where you
know pretty easily I was readily
available to support in a way that I
very much needed to be there which was
very unusual yeah
and I I'm very grateful for that I would
like to think that I would have made the
right decision to change whatever I was
doing in order to be there anyway but I
don't I don't I don't know if if I would
have made the right decision because I
was still wrestling with the selfishness
of like my plans my life
time my desires my comfort you know it
was I mean it's again I'm it's him it's
embarrassing to talk about but I feel
like that's that's part of my takeaway
in terms of my growth in this situation
is you know what really is love in this
situation it's making a decision to be
there
well aspiring to be better at loving
somebody that I do love and knowing that
I just didn't that I had so many
competing personal desires
that were just lame you know it was sure
yeah it's it's difficult to go through
that it's difficult to to hang out at a
hospital it's difficult to know what to
talk about it's like but really these
are like these are things that in your
own brain you would complain about
everybody I think most people most
people would I mean there are some
people who are there are some people who
are naturally I mean my wife being one
of them naturally equipped to just you
know like she can walk into the hospital
room with Louis and she a she knows
exactly what to say she knows what I'm
saying she knows what to do and she and
she could talk to you she could talk to
somebody forever I come in and I'm like
welcome to California I mean I make a
joke right in in and which is helpful
but yeah it's kind of I relate to that
because it's like searching for how did
I get myself in this situation well and
a lot of times I don't know what to do
here well my instincts don't apply well
and I've actually in in many different
ways this is one of the advantages and
did I don't know if the advantages and
disadvantages of being married to
someone who compliments you in a certain
way right who has a characteristic like
for me I can just be like oh Jessie is
really good at that like she knows what
to say she knows how to comfort somebody
so the unit of retinue can comfort
someone because Jesse will do it because
I can't do it and for me it's a it's
part of what you're saying which is just
like well I got too much I got too much
stuff I got to get to I mean my my stuff
that I got to worry about it's more
important than this right part of it
that that's that and then the other side
is just feeling inadequate and also what
happens when the comforting aspect of
the unit is the one that needs
comforting you know it's like it kind of
breaks down internally at that point -
right that's when you hire someone oh no
no yeah it exactly that's that's where
that's where it comes it's not a good
thing I'm saying it's you end up
creating a your deficit can grow because
you're relying on someone and I feel
that and I learned so much from Christie
to be able to meet people's needs and
have empathy you know I guess that's
what we're talking about right we're
talking about being empathetic yeah part
of it and it it again that's why I have
I'm so I'm so in awe of of people who
devote their lives in the field of
Nursing and you know all the people who
would the people who would come in and
clean the room you know the the the
assistants to the nurses everybody who
would who have devoted their lives to
caring for people in that way is just
it's it just it it's amazing and it
draws into focus ways that I can kind of
step up and be a better person I think I
think in watching those people and you
know dealing with the patients and even
in in the moments of frustration and in
confusion and just having composure and
still having just just he just bringing
a just bringing healing to a situation
is something that I don't know my eyes
were really open to that I think when
Lilly's situation was different because
it was it was a plan
procedure and it was a controlled
recovery that we were prepared for but
so there was there was never any huge
scrambling emergency moment I think
that's the difference here that then
there were there were ugly aspects to it
you noted that to this experience that I
I witnessed firsthand people stepping up
and and helping well and what it makes
me think about is the people who you
know Louis he's home now right so it was
an incredibly difficult week full of
lessons but what if the second week was
just like the first week in the third
week was just like the second week and
people who have their their lives turned
upside down because someone big becomes
critically ill terminally ill like if it
happens to somebody in your family to
have it's morning your children and then
all of a sudden your life basically
becomes what you're talking about
mm-hmm and that is that becomes your new
normal which again I mean I'm gonna keep
plugging in st. Jude we did not I didn't
expect to but they helped us understand
right all the support that a that a
family needs like they have they have a
program it's st. Jude that is
specifically designed for siblings of
terminally ill kids and and because what
they've seen is that these kids they
have emotional needs - yeah and when all
the attention and all the resources are
going on this person who is sick what
happens what happens to you I mean I
think in in the the book and the movie
wonder is all you know it they talk
about the the older sisters you know
story anyways all that to say st. Jude
is is sort of like love in action you're
talking about like what you can do
personally and they've kind of created a
whole system to support that kind of
love and action
it's kind of this experience I think is
it's just kind of jostled me awake to my
unwarranted expectations that my life is
gonna be continued to be what I expected
to be you know
well we've we experienced so much
positive things and it's like you know
you start in this conversation we start
to feel a little guilty about it but I
just know that I want to feel guilty I
want to be grateful but I also want not
to live my life as if I expect or demand
no curveballs
you know well yeah I mean I that I and
we talked about this before there are
many times when things are going well
and I think both of our personalities
are actually geared towards all right
kind of expecting something to go wrong
because it just thinks shouldn't you
know things are going well right now so
surely the bottoms got to drop out
somewhere and in and sort of just
anticipating that something like that
will happen but also at the same time
knowing I am NOT emotionally prepared
and I'm also not like I am also too
selfish right now to be able to take
this yeah something that would
inconvenience me to that level yeah I'll
I'll share one more image something that
I want to a memory that I want to stick
with me I'll I'll share with you in
order to help solidify it since
sometimes maybe same stories helps me
remember them or at least now I'll have
an audio record oh gosh we must have
been three days in day it started
allowing him to drink and eat some like
liquefied foods but then they they had
evidence that he might have been
bleeding again
so they it was kind of a panic mode for
a few minutes and then they pulled well
not a few minutes but longer than that
they decided to pull back and he's not
allowed to eat or drink anything as they
monitored him monitored him now it turns
out that he was not bleeding anymore but
it was a that was a setback in terms of
his experience and it you're combining
the hospital on the opposite coast with
me supporting you every morning alone no
he was he was very gracious but it was
very frustrating to not even be able to
drink water at all and it was so it was
you know it was tough to keep his
spirits up and the television helped I
know at home like he he falls asleep to
the television on its way that's like
his white noise so that helped him get
some rest and then but the thing that
happened a few hours later after the
step backwards not being able to even
drink anything and him like literally
being parched the television went just a
fuss he didn't say a word but I'm
thinking oh my gosh this is like this is
like the main thing that feels like
we're holding this together now it's
just the television there's no food
there's nobody else with me to talk to
and now the television is like weak
signal it said like signal cannot be
acquired and then I'm like panicking
inside and I'm like trying to put on a
positive face and my well what do we
what do we do now and then I'm like I
stood up and I'm like I look at the
television kind of like when you open
the hood of your car when you know
something's wrong with it and you're
supposed to look at the motor before you
decide to get someone who's qualified to
fix it like look at the television what
do we do now and so I'm staying in there
at the foot of the bed and then I was
like I was like
it looks like I'm your only form of
entertainment and then I just started
doing a I guess I'll call it an Irish
jig like it was it was it was kind of a
Riverdance thing there was some elbow
movement though and a lot of leg
movements and some kicking how long did
that last
um till I got winded till I got a smile
out of him and then I was like do you
have any cash he said no I don't I don't
have any I don't know where my wallet is
and I was like well then I'm not gonna
strip for you and then I got a laugh out
of him and it was the first time he had
laughed I don't know since before he
landed and and then it I so that helped
but then I ended up unplugging the
television and doing all sorts of
religious ceremonies in my own brain and
plugging it back in and it started
working so we got Leave It to Beaver
back on and some prices right but and
then they started introducing allowing
him to eat drink water and then eat
these like iseas like lemon ices but he
had been talking about these lemon ices
because they had let him have them and
then they took him away and then a whole
day later he's like talking about these
lemon ices anything at that point
oh gosh it was like a it was like a
mirage in the room I felt like and they
finally get they finally told him he can
have one and yeah I brought it in there
and this is like a culmination of like
hours and hours of being fixated on it
and then he's he had this lemon ice and
he's eating I'm like how's that lemon
ice oh I said what did you say he said
he said I like that lemon ice I was like
no what did you say and he says good
good good and I said that's exactly
right so I'll never forget that
well now what happened to the cows
they're fine
what happens with brothers and some they
he had someone else who helps with the
farm to help with because at Ted Fred or
Ned I don't know who's the cowboy all of
them the cows are taking care of we got
him on a plane his daughter picked him
up drove them home they got home that
night it was ten o'clock at night after
a long day of traveling but he was doing
fine evidence being right when they got
home they took their luggage in the
house and then Alice and his daughter
told Christy it's like took the luggage
in the house and then he immediately
came back outside grabbed the leaf
blower and started blowing off his
carport and then the next morning he got
up and he said he was going out the door
and mom said well are you kidding where
you going it's like I'm getting on the
Gator I'm going out there she said we
can't go out there without me I got to
get ready my mom my mom she likes to get
she likes to take her time he takes a
while to get ready well she likes to
take her time well okay just say it's a
choice I'm just saying I remember from
my childhood and he was like no I'm
going out right now and she said well
let me put on my housecoat and then she
was telling Christian she was like so
for the first time ever here I am at
just my housecoat well driving around
out there in the cow see you and then so
he surveyed his property came back
parked the Gator went inside sat down in
his recliner and mom said that was the
first time he seemed 100% at ease in
over a weekend he's back in his environs
yeah so he's doing well he's got to he's
got to tackle these ulcers long term and
figure it out and that they're gonna
monitor that and they're gonna figure
they're gonna get there by the drive of
why it's happening right but he didn't
have to stay in California to deal with
all of that so he's doing that back home
and like I said I talked to him right
before we came in here and he said he
was in a meeting
yeah with some guys and that he was
doing something tonight so he's like
probably dead too and bread oh yeah the
brother summit but Cindy Lewis my love
my father-in-law and I don't know thank
you for hearing me out I don't know take
from it what you will
I know I've taken a lot from the
experience and I'm grateful to have had
it
even though it was in no way easy very
feel very grateful for the for the
outcome for for him and for mom thank
you for sharing link you're welcome
we'll close with a quick wreck I'm going
to recommend a another podcast podcast
that I've been listening to that we are
in no way affiliated with but I really
like called science versus it is a
approximately half hour weekly podcast
where they very simply take a subject of
any kind it might be like climate change
it might be DNA like you know hereditary
companies it might be vaccines it might
be gun control it's basically just
issues that people throw all kinds of
opinions out and they say we're only
going to talk about what this with the
latest science is they do like upwards
of a hundred you know resources or
references in each podcast to it's very
well researched half-hour and if you're
the kind of person is just an
inquisitive mind and you want to know
what the science says about a particular
thing you can just scroll through
they've already addressed a lot of
different subjects and keep coming out
with weekly episodes so science versus
recommend it vs RVers us it's just vs
okay easier yeah there you have it
another ear biscuit in the can hashtag
ear biscuits let us know if any part of
this conversation or the experience I
shared resonates with you in any way I'd
love to hear from you
hashtag ear biscuits will speak at you
again next week because that's what we
do well that's what we plan on doing
weekly yeah
we plan on it I'm just saying I don't
know what life could throw at us bro if
it all lines up will bring another
biscuit your way yep to watch more ear
biscuits click on the playlist on the
right to watch the previous episode of
your biscuits click on the playlist to
the left and don't forget to click on
the circular icon to subscribe if you
prefer to listen to this podcast it's
available on all your favorite podcast
platforms thanks for being your mythical
best
[Music]